[Musique]
alexandre c'est la surprise est en grève
ou pas c'est tellement jubilatoire de la
revoir dans la saison 2 ans une vraie
folle prête à tout donc d'autant plus
prête à tout pour gagner mais pour
gagner pour marc
tu te ridiculise devant tout le monde et
tu me fous la route dans la saison 2
voilà encore plus folles sont le premier
qui bouge sera éliminé éliminé du jeu
avec moi je peux le faire
alexandra je vais te dire un truc
dont on
tient compte sur mon dos
oui c'est que tout pour marc les gogos
qui était assez drôle c'est que je je
porte marque sur des épaules havrais qui
fait bout d'un peu plus de 80 kg et mais
pour elle tout c'est tout à fait normal
c'est elle qui veut porte sur son dos et
je penche tout le trajet
qu'il faut trésor s'est assis là angie
batterie là tout est trop lent c'est
rolland s'est prolongée à pied
la première saison quand on quand on va
tourner je me souviens qu'une fois
jonathan m'a dit
il faut que tu le sens appelle moi
peut-être pour rien me dire je ne sais
pas il faut qu'on trouve un truc et
c'est là que ça a commencé mais c'était
pas forcément les cris
[Applaudissements]
et ça c'était génial la deuxième saison
il y avait un truc hockey se dire
alexandra faut pas que je retarde la
même chose
c'est moussa dia qu'avec le personnage
de marque que je peux m jonathan cohen
sur mes ongles vu que ça fait ben moi
qu'on a commencé le tournage il ya il ya
déjà des doigts où il ait pu et donc je
me parla je parle à mes dix marques et
en fait j'ai l'impression que marc en
train de mourir donc je pleure et voilà
c'est donc du coup on peut faire des
scènes un peu comme sa barque
c'est génial je joue je boude pas mon
plaisir quoi
un petit je me suis racheté la
telenovela city puisque alexandra n'est
pas censé être la barre des banques
c'est comme si c'était marco quand marc
alexandre à ce qu'on s'est paraît il se
voit peut-être à travers d'autres gens
et donc je serai confessions je suis mal
qu il ajouté ça tombe mal parce que
marcos et pas marc ton coach va te
[ __ ] donc eu vent jonathan part de
parcours on n'a pas encore retrouvé la
flamme de le quitter je veux que tu m'as
pas dire mais je te partie repris thomas
parker et il parle de marco et puis me
voilà cherchent-elles acteur et il
faut que ce soit toi qu'il joue ennemie
c'est fou parce qu'on en a parlé ce
matin
et je sais pas bref il ne fait pas pour
sa part depuis cinq minutes
elle part avec marco tu m'aimes et comme
eux comme personne ne va jamais
mais voilà l'amour belle et mais ça se
comprend pas moins qu'on met elle pas un
bug marque mais bon mais alexandra le
sera elle partira jamais vraiment qu'est
ce que tu accepterais que j'allais vivre
cet amour marque ben oui bien sûr
[Musique]
ça lui
allait pas
[Musique]